Тут не буде точно, що два місяці ми пропустили під час карантину
і два місяці нам знадобиться в наступному році навчальному.
Мають бути дезінфектори, ми думаємо про проведення температурного скринінгу.
Найважливіше – це збереження життя і здоров’я дітей
і всіх учасників освітнього процесу.
Щонайменше 3 тижні, до 11 травня, українські школярі та студенти навчатимуться дистанційно.
Чи повернуться учні за парти цього навчального року, як складатимуть ЗНО випускники
та як оцінюватимуть знання, отримані під час карантину, -
сьогодні обговорюємо з Любомирою Мандзій,
яка виконує обов’язки міністра освіти і науки України.
Любомиро Степанівно, Ви обійняли посаду міністра вже під час карантину
і цей період виявився складним для освітньої галузі.
Як би Ви оцінили дистанційну освіту в школах нині за дванадцятибальною системою?
Не буду мати можливості виставляти бали в межах 12, я можу говорити про поступ.
На старті ми мали невідомість,
але в теперішніх умовах вже зараз школи використовують дуже багато ресурсів
для організації уроків через використання технологій дистанційного навчання.
Найбільшою проблемою для нас є технічна можливість доступу до інтернету,
особливо з боку учнів.
У нас лише 3 відсотки шкіл не були підключені до інтернету,
але ми не маємо інформації про кількість домівок, які не підключені до інтернету.
Тому вчителі використовують різні шляхи взаємодії зі своїми учнями.
Дистанційне навчання ще раз оголило прірву між міськими і сільськими школами
щодо якості освіти, тому що у багатьох учнів немає інтернету
або немає гаджетів, якими вони могли би скористатися.
Як бути з цією категоріє учнів, щоби все-таки забезпечити їх теж належною освітою?
Закладам освіти рекомендовано передбачити час для підсумування, узагальнення матеріалу,
вивчення якого передбачене було на час картину.
Це так зване коригуюче навчання.
Провести додаткові заняття для пояснення матеріалу.
Але тут є дуже різні можливості і тут немає теж єдиного підходу,
от ми виділяємо два тижні чи тиждень, тому що зараз учителі працюють,
але їм потрібно діагностувати ситуацію і це можна буде зробити у вересні місяці,
якщо дозволить епідеміологічна ситуація.
Тут не буде точно, що два місяці ми пропустили під час карантину
і два місяці нам знадобиться в наступному році навчальному.
Тут вже виключно індивідуальний підхід, немає уніфікованого рішення,
що усім школам необхідний тиждень.
А може якісь школі необхідно два, а може місяць часу. Тут дуже індивідуально.
Пані Любомиро, розкажіть, будь ласка, про  те, як закінчуватиметься цей навчальний рік.
Коли він може закінчитися, як учні переходитимуть з одного класу в інший?
Що буде з випускниками, що буде з першачками,
тому що дуже багато насправді запитань у батьків і в самих учнів.
Щодо закінчення навчального року Міністерство освіти рекомендувало закладам освіти
зберегти структуру навчального року відповідно до затвердженої у вересні місяці.
Це означає, що опановуємо матеріал зазвичай до закінчення травня,
проводимо підсумкові оцінювання, тематичне, підсумкове.
Маємо підготувати документи про закінчення навчального року.
Направити електронною поштою або копією, це має бути індивідуально для кожного учня.
Якщо учні закінчують 9 клас, то замовити документи і видати документи про освіту
для того, що випускники 9 класу мали можливість
в подальшому вибрати собі той заклад освіти, в якому вони мають намір продовжувати навчання.
Тобто навіть якщо 11 травня буде скасовано карантин, то до навчання,
фізичної присутності в школі діти навряд чи, на Вашу думку, повернуться?
Якщо епідеміологічна ситуація дозволить поновити навчання в школах,
нам необхідно забезпечити безпечність цих шкіл і тоді повернути туди учнів.
Любомиро Степанівно, розкажіть ще детальніше про оці 2 сценарії проведення ЗНО цьогоріч.
Яким чином буде забезпечена безпека цих учнів, які складатимуть тести?
Чи будуть там дезінфектори, маски?
5188 закладів освіти визначені як пункти
тестування зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання.
Безперечно, ми маємо забезпечити соціальну дистанцію між учасниками,
безперечно, ми маємо забезпечити безпечність закладу, мають бути дезінфектори.
Ми думаємо про проведення температурного скринінгу і обов’язково засоби гігієни.
Тобто діти писатимуть, ймовірно, в масках і рукавичках?
Ми всі разом розуміємо, що ми маємо жити в нових реаліях.
І якщо у нас зміниться епідеміологічна ситуація, то у нас нікуди не дінеться пандемія.
Ми всі разом є соціально відповідальні за наше майбутнє.
На тих самих батьківських форумах, в групі «Батьки SOS»
зараз обговорюється дистанційне навчання
і є багато нарікань на вчителів.
І це породжує з одного боку породжує дискредитацію традиційної освіти,
а з іншої боку якусь надмірну конфліктність.
Як Ви гадаєте, як з цього можна вийти?
Ми розуміємо, що в період карантину
реальними учасниками освітнього процесу стають батьки.
І батьки теж повинні підтримати своїх дітей,
не конфліктувати, не загострювати ситуацію, а навпаки підтримувати.
За результатами міжнародних досліджень,
успіху досягають ті діти, які мають суттєву підтримку з боку вчителів і з боку батьків.
Тут важливо в цій ситуації, яка виникла в Україні і в світі, підтримка одне одного.
Не конфлікт, а навпаки підтримка.
Чи є зараз моніторинг проблем, які виникають, якихось труднощів,
щоби цей нинішній карантинний період вплинув на навчальні програми в майбутньому.
Я думаю, що виходячи з сьогоднішніх реалій і майбутніх викликів,
точно вчителі використовуватимуть більше інструментів,
технологій, пов’язаних з дистанційним навчанням.
У мене ще питання стосовно вищої освіти.
Як захищатимуть люди свої дипломні роботи, як складатимуть студенти сесію?
Тому що в листі Міністерства освіти йдеться про те, що це може бути он-лайн,
але треба забезпечити ідентифікацію студентів. Яким чином це можна зробити?
Які умови будуть в червні для того, щоб повернулися студенти в заклади вищої освіти,
буде залежати від епідеміологічної ситуації.
Але заклади вищої освіти були більш технічно забезпечені
і мали більше напрацювань з використанням різних платформ
для проведення дистанційного навчання.
Тому зараз і викладачі, і студенти працюють дистанційно.
Цей процес ми моніторимо
і в подальшому вони мають бути готовими і до дистанційного закінчення навчального року.
Вже третій тиждень працює дистанційна школа он-лайн. Наскільки вона ефективна?
По відгуках батьків і учнів вони досить є позитивними.
Це додатковий інструмент, який може використати учень для опанування матеріалу.
Окрім цього ці уроки можна переглянути на ютуб каналі Міністерства освіти і науки.
І вони в зручний для учня час.
Чи будуть розроблені подібні уроки для молодшої школи?
Так, ми зараз над цим працюємо. Тут є свої особливості.
В дітей початкової школи важливим, власне, є такий контакт з вчителем.
І це інше сприйняття, інша концентрація уваги,
тому ми зараз працюємо, але це не будуть такі уроки, як уроки в традиційному розумінні.
Це буде пояснення матеріалу.
Не можу Вас не запитати про помилки, які допускали вчителі в попередні тижні,
і які набули такого розголосу.
Ви як педагог і як міністр як ставитесь до подібних речей?
Це технологічний процес, де ми не могли зразу одномоментно запустити і експертизу.
У нас на це просто не було часу.
Ми на це відреагували, долучивши до проекту пул вчителів-експертів, які присутні під час запису
і учителів-експертів, які працюють  дистанційно
і які переглядають матеріал, який згодом вийде в ефір.
У нас є ще декілька запитань від наших підписників, які залишали їх у Фейсбуці.
Одне із них стосується формальностей шкільної освіти,
зокрема ведення зошита, вимог до оформлення робіт і так далі.
Карантин показав, що ці формальні речі менш важливі.
І чи планує міністерство внести зміни в навчальний процес
і змінити вимоги до педагогів з огляду на досвід, отриманий за ці два місяці?
Ми плануємо дещо змінювати,
тому що реалізуючи нову українську школу, ми готуємо дитину до життя.
Вона має бути готова до життя,
а не тільки передбачені чіткі вимоги або заповнення в зошиті,
скільки клітинок треба відступити, до прикладу, коли ми пишемо дату чи класну роботу.
Думаю, що ці вимоги ми теж будемо змінювати.
Вчителі теж залишали для Вас запитання і декілька з них стосувалися контрактів,
які будуть підписані з вчителями пенсійного віку, починаючи з першого липня.
Мовляв, вони суперечать Конституції України
і можливо в такому випадку варто було би підписувати контракти
з усім педагогічним складом школи, незалежно від віку вчителя.
Що Ви на це скажете?
Переведення вчителів, які досягли пенсійного віку, на строкові трудові договори
передбачено законом «Про повну загальну середню освіту».
Міністерство освіти дало роз’яснення закладам освіти, директорам,
що це не звільнення з роботи педагогічних працівників,
а переведення на строкові трудові договори.
За цими учителями зберігається виплата відпускних, оздоровлення,
тобто все зберігається так, як було.
Це норма закону «Про повну загальну середню освіту» і ми повинні їх виконувати.
Закінчення карантину не означає закінчення пандемії вірусу і вірусологи, на жаль,
передбачають, що може статися новий спалах восени
чи ближче до зими разом з сезонним грипом.
Чи буде готова система освіти реагувати оперативно й ефективно
і з точки зору навчального процесу, і з точки зору безпеки, якщо буде в цьому потреба?
Так, безперечно, ми опрацюємо уроки, які ми зараз отримали
в час першого, так би мовити, періоду карантину.
І ми їх опрацюємо, виконаємо домашнє завдання.
З 1 вересня будемо мати нові нормативні документи  для того,
щоб система освіти могла реагувати на виклики, які пов’язані з пандемією.
Я повністю з вами погоджуюся, що закінчення карантину не означає, що закінчилися пандемія.
Ми мусимо спільно разом навчитися жити в нових реаліях, в нових вимогах.
І найважливіше – це збереження життя і здоров’я дітей і всіх учасників освітнього процесу
і нам важливо забезпечити безпечність освітнього середовища.